foreign
concerned about having a repeat of covet
authoritarianism in the name of climate
change it has forced me to take another
look at the expert opinions expert
opinions are you familiar with the
scientist Tony Heller he's on Odyssey
and runs realclimatescience.com I'd be
interested in an evolutionary
perspective on his work
I don't think I know Tony Heller I don't
recognize that particular name no
um but I would offer a caution
I think we can be certain covet has
revealed what broken science looks like
and there is essentially no chance that
climate science doesn't suffer from the
same kind of dysfunction climate science
is not going to be open to
countervailing evidence right which it
would have to be in order to understand
how strong the evidence actually is
that's right that said the discovery
that what we think is evidence all the
work that goes on that claims to
understand how intense the problem is
and where it's likely to go the fact
that that is all compromised by
scientism
does not suggest that we don't have a
problem and there are reasons to suggest
that we have a problem that do not
emerge from that modern uh
discipline
in fact the belief that climate change
is a hazard is very old and it arises
from an extremely simple easy to
demonstrate feature of
chemistry atmospheric chemistry right
and
the point is yes CO2 traps Heat
it is embedded in a complex system so
it's hard to know what the net impact is
going to be we are altering the amount
of CO2 in the atmosphere nobody uh
doubts that and how could it be
otherwise the amount of internal
combustion that we are doing cannot help
but have that effect so the question is
is it negligible
is it alarming and further what is the
interaction with things like frozen
methane in the Arctic there's a huge
amount of methane larger large amounts
tied up in these methane clathrate
Composites and to the extent that we
melt novel amounts of that stuff we are
going to step into a realm across a
threshold where it's a positive feedback
that is completely out of our control
will we reach that threshold I don't
know but I can say it is foolish to risk
that our industrial processes will push
us across that threshold it is even more
foolish to risk
um the entire
catastrophe unfolding as a result of the
fact that we have allowed political
Dogma to overwhelm scientific study what
we really need are excellent scientists
working on the question completely free
to discover whatever it is that's out
there so that they can help us see and
navigate at the moment what we are doing
is Flying Blind because the very people
who sit in the seats of the scientists
who need to be warning us their
discipline is compromised by the belief
that we already know the answer and that
anything that points in the other
direction is going to embolden the
opposition so we can't afford to talk
about it
and coming to opposite conclusions gets
you blacklisted gets you you know you
you don't end up having a career uh
that's standard as a climate scientist
right now which which is
you know what it is the whole thing is
suspect unfortunately and it's it's just
dire
it's runaway climate science
I'm afraid yeah just that's the long and
short of it yeah run away climate
science which obscures whatever is going
on you're right you're right
sometimes you're right sometimes I'm
right oh wow this is good you know that
I mean I did I didn't know you knew that
yes you did yeah
[Music]